mon meilleur moment dans touche pas à
mon poste vraiment happening c'est
l'homme canon parce qu'il faut bien
savoir que on est conditionné à chaque
fois dans l'épreuve notamment via la
boîte cyril qui nous fait croire que
c'est un truc à lui sinon j'allais l'on
va allumer la mèche du canot au plus
tard [ __ ] y avait donc un canon on
nous avait passé une vidéo du gac a
battu le record du monde aux états unis
et pour moi j'étais l'homme volant est
en fait je me prépare à faire un vol de
chou bat le record du monde je me mets
dans le canon et là je saute dans le
canon et puis après je tombe comme une
merde il faut bien le dire une blouse
sur un sac en plastique
le pire moment dans touche pas à mon
poste je crois que c'est quand j'ai
tendu une main matthieu delormeau et
qu'il a refusé à matthieu delormeau
je pardonne on se parlait plus beaucoup
pour différentes raisons
moi je pensais que c'était de sa faute
et lui qu'on sait que c'est la mienne je
critiquais beaucoup c'est prime et c'est
enfin voilà ça n'allait pas et je
profite vraiment l'occasion d'un prime
pour lui tendre la main
matthieu delormeau est-ce qu'il a mis je
te pardonne les coups pour coups
et là je me suis sentie mal pas vexer
parce que c'est pas de la vexation mais
mal parce que j'avais envie vraiment de
rétablir pour l'émission pour le bien de
l'émission on et collègues
il s'agissait vraiment de retisser les
liens et je lui avais proposé il m'avait
jetée vous êtes vous êtes triste j'ai le
défoncer
alors l'invitée qui m'a le plus marqué
évidemment pour moi ça symbolise un
clash c'est celui avec lorànt deutsch et
j'avais été un peu trop agressif c'est
mon défaut parfois je m'emporte à douala
dans les pêcheurs au travail moi je suis
pas le personnage que vous êtes mon nom
mais je sais pourtant que ressent la
même chose de vraiment déroule toujours
vous réfléchi et là non je répète pas
toujours pas à votre sort dans les
salles
à votre tour de mesloub à l'est de la
france à votre tour 2007 il avait lu mon
livre à votre tour dans les allées du
nir avant quoi les il ya toujours des
lunes partie j'en ai donc pas mais faux
fichiers non je peux pas et bien parce
que au xviie siècle parce que c'est un
livre réac mais aussi et ce clash
lavedan souvient vraiment c'était pour
moi un des plus beaux pugilat oratoire
que j'ai vu dans tous parents